we took a lot of pride in in
trailblazing and how the game was played
I knew at that time when I was 8 I
wanted to be an entertainer and I loved
the idea of that it wasn't me personally
that they didn't like it was that I
wasn't being me light and brings like
drama and you're gonna deal with this
person and your relationship yes I get
up at crazy hours whether it's 3 o'clock
in the morning by the way when we're
talking in London I was getting up at
3:00 because I had to be on set by 4:00
it is a worst mistake you will ever make
he said you're ruining your career love
action and I love kicking ass but the
goal is to become a better actor get
your ass kicked
get back up and you put the gloves back
on and you swing away when I was 16
years old that was the last time that I
was arrested I don't know how it
happened but my cousin who was on tour
with us I said just got busted with
prostitutes and my name is attached to
it now he's a Canadian American actor
producer and semi-retired wrestler the
rock is considered by many to be the
biggest superstar in WWE history his
autobiography debuted at number one on
the New York Times bestseller list
he's Dwayne the rock Johnson and hear
his top ten rules for success we were
bad we intimidated we dominated but we
took a lot of pride in that we took a
lot of pride in in trailblazing and how
the game was played back at that time
through we would we would intimidate
teams and we would want to dominate
teams but also too we also had the
thought process of a team was never
going to outwork us we're going to be
the hardest working team in the country
and check this out what we would do for
example we would go into we will go into
so we had a big game gets Florida State
so we will go into there Doak Campbell
Stadium and instead of going through
your general practice what you do what
we would do is we would do things a
little bit different just to intimidate
them so as a team we would kind of all
line up we're in their stadium you got
their staff you got some players
watching us instead of going through our
plays we would just start to give
cadence calls so for example you know
the whole team we would say things like
you know
Oh hahaha bagged wing we would say all
the skeins we got an itch Florida
State's gonna be our [ __ ] like that I
wanted to entertain I know when I was
eight years old I thought I was a
combination of these guys I thought I
was a combination of Chuck Norris
Richard Pryor Harrison Ford and Rocky
Balboa and Harrison Ford from Indiana
Jones I was like all these guys in my oh
and Elvis Presley two at 8:00 right II
love the ambitious yes exactly uh so I
knew at that time when I was eight I
wanted to be an entertainer and I love
the idea of that and what it meant and
when I was eight I saw Indiana Jones for
the first time and I love that character
like wow that guy was so heroic and he
kicked ass and he I remember I had great
angst every night before I went out
because I was not able to be myself
my very first WrestleMania biggest show
of the year the Superbowl of wrestling
that night 20,000 fans started chanting
rocky sucks it was a sobering moment and
that was the beginning of the end of my
initial run in the WWE
a few weeks later a tour tendon to my
knee and I was out for the rest of the
summer and I came to the realization
before I went back that it wasn't me
personally that they didn't like it was
then I wasn't being me I wasn't being
real wasn't being authentic who is this
guy in wrestling who's smiling when he's
getting beat few weeks later I got a
call from the WWE and I spoke to Vince
McMahon he said when you come back we
could continue to shove you down
people's throats or we could turn your
heel because they want to boo you anyway
I said I think it's a great idea and I
said before we get off the phone I have
one request I said when I come back and
we go live I just need two minutes live
me talking to the audience live two
minutes is all I'm asking he said okay
you got a couple of weeks later I came
back we're on live TV I grabbed the
microphone
fans were already booing he started
chanting rocky sucks
and arenas across the country by her
chance of rocky sucks
I said um I may be a lot of things but
sucks isn't one of them but sucks isn't
one of them in that moment the rock was
born and about a month later I was a
hottest heel in the company and things
were on fire and the greatest lesson
about that is be you be yourself whether
it's in entertainment whether it's out
in public whether your celebrity or not
whatever the most powerful thing you can
be as yourself yes I get up super early
generally I have this thing where I like
beating the Sun up not just in terms of
what Sun come down I have to get up and
how do I do it it's just important to
find balance and I try and do things
really that I really enjoy doing and a
lot of times you know it's like in life
right life brings like drama and you're
gonna deal with this person and if your
relationship here in all these things
you try and just kind of balance them
out as best I can I got a great team
around me by the way who really really
helps me well and helps me allows for me
to come in and work 12 hours a day 14
hours a day get up at 3 o'clock in the
morning send out an Instagram video
where I'm talking to my cardio machine
like a crazy maniac
requires a lot of be around yes I get up
at crazy hours whether it's three
o'clock in the morning by the way when
we were talking in London I was getting
up at 3:00 because I had to be on set by
4:00 I'm sorry by 7:00 so whatever time
my call time is and I tell this to
studios and directors and our producers
whatever tell my call time so my call
time is at 7:00 then you back your clock
up four hours and then that's when I get
up and train twice or get my cardio in
and breakfast and I'll go hit the
weights clanging and banging we call it
Jack and the iron but like what time do
you go to bed I mean you might shoot
really late at night I'm averaging on a
movie on average probably about five
hours of sleep okay I found that with
depression one of the most important
things you could realize is that you're
not alone you're not the first to go
through it you're not going to be the
last to go through it and oftentimes it
happens you just you feel like you're
alone and you feel like it's only you
and you're in your bubble and and I wish
I had someone at that time who
who could just pull me signed a it's
gonna be okay it'll be okay so wish I
knew that just gotta remember hold on to
that fundamental quality of faith have
faith
and on the other side of your pain is
something good after about a month and a
half of staying in that little apartment
and cleaning I got a phone call from the
head coach of the team who cut me the
head coach of the Calgary Stampeders he
called me and he said hey I know we cut
you but I'd like you to come back I said
okay I appreciate that coach thank you
very much I'll think about it he said
okay great I hung up the phone and um my
dad said you gonna do it right I said no
I don't think so I think I'm done with
that
and he goes what I said my gut tells me
I'm done he said what he gonna do I took
a deep breath I said I'd like to get
into the business he said what business
I said the wrestling business he says
you are throwing it all away
it is a worst mistake you will ever make
he said you're ruining your career
I said maybe I'll be no good but I feel
like in my heart I have to do this and I
either need you to train me or need you
to not train me my dad rose to the
occasion so don't train and it wound up
being one of the greatest chapters in my
life the goal this is my tenth year of
acting that goal was always to work in
and I started in the action genre yeah
love action and I love kicking ass but
the goal is to become a better actor and
so for me in order for me to do that I
had to work in all different genres so I
wanted to explore family movies comedies
action comedies family comedies mixed
drama into as well so that was important
to me was just to get better I knew I
wanted to be something and it was
important to me to be something it was
it was important to me that I didn't
fail but by the way and if I did fail at
least that what was also important was
the lesson and I didn't realize that
until I got older because you know when
you're in it you're in the grind you
don't really recognize those things when
you're younger but I could recognize
them now and the importance of them now
any
just in terms of the drive and the
determination a lot of it was
experienced to get your ass kicked
get back up and you put the gloves back
on and you swing away when I was 16
years old that was the last time that I
was arrested and at that time we were we
were at an all-time low I think with our
family and at that time we were living
in Bethlehem Pennsylvania and I am
already a pretty big boy six foot four
200 maybe 2025 pounds I had a very bad
mustache
I had a chip on my shoulder fresh into
this high school in Bethlehem
Pennsylvania Freedom High School I
wanted use the bathroom but I didn't
want to use the regular boy's bathroom
because the boy's bathroom smelled like
smoke and all the other fun stuff that
boy's bathroom smell like so I'd go into
the teachers lounge and a teacher comes
in his name is Jody Swick tough guy he
says hey you can't be in here
I kind of pause look over my shoulder
okay I'll leave when I'm done and I
continue to wash my hands I slowly dry
my hands and I walk by him and I kind of
just looked at him I'll walk by he
looked at me didn't say a word but he
was fuming I went home that night and I
felt bad I just felt bad very next day I
found him and I went to see him in his
class and I said done I said I just want
to apologize for how I acted yesterday
and I'm sorry and I stuck my hand out
and he looked at my hand and looked at
me looked at my hand again he shook my
hand
I'll never forget that shake you
wouldn't let it go
so I want you to do something for me yes
when she come out and play football for
me I said okay I said all right every
word yeah sure you got my word and think
much of it I thought okay yeah play some
football like playing football sure cool
and I went honest and I played football
for for Jody swig and he was our head
football coach and he became a father
figure to me in a mentor I fell in love
with a game of football
my grades got better and I started
getting recruited from every college
across the country college coaches will
come in you say there is Brian Johnson
six for 250 plays both sides of the ball
very aggressive my thought process
started to change that's when I started
thing about goals and what I wanted to
accomplish and I love that man I'll
never forget the impact that he had in
my life and the reminder and my takeaway
from that amazing relationship that I
had was the empathy that he had for a
punk kid who treated him so rudely and
disrespectfully
he looked past that BS and said I
believe in you and I want to turn you
around often times when I see kids and
they have been labeled all that punk
kids true there's good in him and we got
to see that potential and I enjoy that
today seeing the potential in kids just
like he did especially kids who are kind
of wayward and I've been going through
it I know what it's like um so thank you
Jody
thank you buddy I love April Fool's but
the thing about it is is I love doing
but my April Fool's runs the entire year
I see yes I'm alive yeah because it's
like April Fool's everyone's expecting
it so this past around Christmastime
we're getting ready to make a big
announcement for a movie and I called my
agent I was I was overseas I call my
agent Brad Slater woke him up in the
middle of the night
and as I came in I got to talk to his
like what's going on what's wrong I said
I don't know how it happened but my
cousin who was on tour with us I said
just got busted with prostitutes and my
name is attached to it now and it's all
getting ready to hit the press he
started freaking out I was like Brad are
you okay he was getting emotional oh my
god what are we gonna do okay hold on it
he goes I'm gonna be calm in the pocket
I'm thinking about this hold on and I
was like I don't know what to do I think
there's multiple prostitutes with this
thing there's a whole ring over here
it's unbelievable had him going and
going and going and finally I was like
Oh Brad Brad Brad he's like what I was
like December Fool digging it's
ridiculous that and there was a long
head yep thank you so much for watching
I made this video because David uen
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it in the comments below I
wanna see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of the
Rock's top ten tips meant the most to
you is gonna have the biggest impact on
your life and business leave it in the
comments and I'll join the discussion
thank you so much for watching continue
to believe and I'll see you soon